the pankin family has a full house
parents galena and alexi have 13 kids
including nine foster children but at
the family dinner table one seat now
sits empty
the parents say their adopted son daniel
was bright funny and full of energy
after their meal the family gathers to
watch this slideshow of photos from his
life which was produced after his death
daniel was a soldier in the russian army
in april just weeks before his 20th
birthday he was killed fighting in
ukraine
he proposed to his girlfriend before he
left for ukraine his mother says our
family was about to get even bigger but
he never made it home
the pankin family while rich in love are
from one of russia's poorest regions
when daniel joined the military last
year it offered housing and a salary
several times larger than the national
average
the russian military was one of the only
stable working enterprises says his
father himself a former soldier we
didn't expect the coming conflict over
ukraine he says
the kremlin has remained tight-lipped on
the number of russians killed in ukraine
but an analysis of around 3 600 soldiers
identified so far found the vast
majority are from some of russia's
poorest most ethnically diverse regions
including the mainly muslim northern
caucasus region and siberia by
comparison only a fraction of the
soldiers came from more affluent cities
of moscow and st petersburg
they came here for the money says this
ukrainian civilian who lived under
russian occupation for a month he says
the soldiers broke into homes and stole
tvs bikes even toilets
they were shocked to see our villages
with such nice roads and houses he says
they told me they were afraid if they
quit the military they would be thrown
in jail but many of their russian
occupiers also seem to genuinely believe
the kremlin's claim that they're
liberating ukraine from nazis
the russians said we've come to save you
and i said save us from whom she says
i'm not afraid we have only begun to
suffer because of putin
like many in russia the ponkin family
receives most of their information about
the so-called special military operation
from state tv
and while they could be jailed for
saying otherwise they blame nato and the
united states for provoking russia
our perception of the military operation
hasn't changed much even after daniel's
death he says if anything i have more
anger now who will stop these people
these animals if not our boys after a
few weeks in ukraine daniel told his
parents he was considering quitting but
didn't want to abandon his friends they
were told he was killed by a ukrainian
tank while providing cover fire for his
comrades he was awarded this medal the
russian order of courage
he didn't die in vain she says he died
fighting for peace
a portrait of a russian soldier poor
young men immersed in putin's propaganda
jeff semple global news